this is the e10s robot vacuum from our
sponsor Eureka featuring a very unique
and special design that actually comes
with a couple of really thoughtful
features that are guaranteed to save you
more time and money than basically any
other Robot vacuum I've seen on the
market it all starts with Eureka's
multicyclone technology which comes
directly from their stick vacuums and
it's built into the base station so when
your robot vacuum is done cleaning it
comes back to the station and
automatically empties itself into the
base station which uses the Cyclones to
separate out large particles preventing
clogging and extending the lifespan of
the HEPA filter both of these things
save you time and money requiring less
filter changes and maintenance and on
top of that the five layer filtration
system captures dust and small particles
keeping them out of your air but the
best part of all is that this
multicyclone technology is combined with
a Bagless dust tank which features a
high capacity that lasts up to 45 days
so it's fully automated and it's very
easy to see how much dirt your robot is
cleaning up also eliminating the need
for disposable bags this Bagless feature
is incredible because it'll save you up
to $70 in dust bags every year which of
course also contributes to protecting
the environment instead of swapping out
bags you simply lift up the tank bring
it over to the trash bin press the empty
button and Bam the dust Falls right out
in you're ready to go for another 45
days so as for the base station I'm very
happy with the quality and the small
details like how you can wrap up the
power cable in the back so it doesn't
stick out now getting into the robot
vacuum itself it was incredibly easy to
unbox and set up featuring loads of
sensors like lar for efficient realtime
mapping and navigation around objects as
well as my favorite detail of all the
fact that it has two spinning brushes so
they work together to to gather crumbs
instead of knocking them all over the
room it features up to 4,000 pas of
suction power which is great for floors
and carpets to clean dirt pet hair or
even crumbs including the carpet boost
feature that automatically detects and
increases the suction to the max to make
sure it's picking everything up the
setup was very easy using the Eureka
robot app which basically has the robot
vacuum create a map of your floor the
first time it cleans use its lar scanner
which is a must these days with robox
you can easily adjust the suction power
in the app schedule cleaning times or
even set up no go zones if you'd like as
well as customizing a bunch of other
settings now on top of all of that the
e10s also supports a basic mopping
function using this mopping pad and they
even include a second pad in the box so
you can swap them out and wash them but
unlike other robovac it comes with with
a special mop raising feature that
raises the mops by 10 mm whenever its
ultrasonic carpet sensors detect carpet
so it avoids getting them all wet it
also raises the mops whenever it returns
to the base station ensuring that the
just mop floors are kept completely
clean and on top of all of that it even
supports voice control with Amazon Alexa
and Google Assistant Alexa turn on
eurobot start
cleaning now as far as my thoughts and
experience with it I've been very
impressed with how well it picks up
crumbs and doesn't flick them around all
over the room thanks to the Dual
spinning brushes so it always does a
very good job there and even though the
mop function is very simple I was
surprised by how wet it was able to get
my floors while whopping so that was
quite nice as well but most of all I
think the Bagless system is great
because I've used stick vacuums before
like the ones from Dyson and it's just
so con convenient to instantly empty the
dust container and get back to vacuuming
without ever having to worry about
replacing a bag and better yet imagine
running out of bags and having to stop
everything drive to the store buy more
bags just to get your vacuum running
again that would be just incredibly
annoying and yes the multicyclone
technology has worked Wonders on the
stick vacuums because the filters really
do last a long time before needing to be
cleaned so that's yet another part of
Maintenance that doesn't need to be done
as often with the Eureka e10s this
robovac is also rated for 180 minutes of
battery life which is honestly more than
enough and it ensures that even the
largest of floors can be cleaned without
running out of battery halfway through
so all in all this is probably the most
reliable maintenance-free and
time-saving Robot vacuum I've seen on
the market and if you're interested you
can order yours today by using the in
the description and pinned comment below
hopefully you enjoy this video and once
again thanks to Eureka for sponsoring
this video and sending over their new
e10s robot vacuum thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
one